hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva and
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
trailer today for last flag flying yeah
that new leak later join the guy who did
before sunrise that whole trilogy School
of Rock and fully hood the remake of Bad
News Bears why does he did that no he
did yeah I did you know what amazes me
about you what could be anything I'm a
pretty amazing guy
you turn the keys to your bar over the
guy who's asleep on your pool table and
then you jump in your car and you drive
me to hell and gone and you don't even
know what we're going to surrender to
god what the hell today we were in the
service together with your pastor I
haven't seen these many decades to
represent our period in my life that
went down awfully quick drinking for two
now you got a hold and boring
because of my son I came here found you
guys a year ago we joined the Corps and
then two days ago they told me that he'd
been killed gonna be buried in Arlington
and I was wondering if you guys could
come with me desert why I'm taking Larry
home with all due respect sir he
deserves to live got Arlington you're
gonna take that back try to make it full
they're cutting off your nose to spite
your face did you look at these faces
they've already been spotted I thought
we were going to a funeral we are going
to a funeral
just looks like it's gonna take a little
longer to get there what you gonna do
strap the coffin on the roof of you call
it could do that seem very different
rest of us yeah happy childhood he said
that yes sir
there's one minute that's not comparable
I'd like to try to enjoy as holiness can
hardly walk let alone handle a big rig
with a hydraulic lift this is a riffle
with an automatic transmission you guys
ready for an adventure let's go
[Music]
I love it it's like the official scent
of the city things that come into your
head and out of your mouth
you worry too much that's why your
heroin so great could you resist a man
in this uniform I don't think I could be
there for you brothers that's all it
really notice okay you want to play
let's play that looks like a Richard
Linklater kind of movie yeah it's hard
to tell how that's gonna be from the
trailer but it's sweet not too heavy a
lot of light Venus a lot of light a lot
of people together yeah plating seems
like sentimental passage of time I'm
excited for these three actors to come
together once Fishburne he was and I
know the matrix was like the big
defining role he had but he was already
pretty popular before the matrix Oh
totally yeah that was just another huge
thing to keep him popular till the end
oh yeah and Bryan Cranston and Steve
Carell both in their 40s got really
famous yeah and seeing them come
together it's fascinating because you
know Bryan Cranston his big breakout
role was knock him in the middle is
defining roles which I think it still is
best you know and Steve Carell too came
onto the scene with comedy as well I
feel like he's still associate Steve
Carell as a funny guy but when you see
him in a drama it's not like why is he
doing this you know it you can slip into
characters really well even if they're
not funny
I think like their acting Styles I can
see them they're not the same but I can
see them meshing well together yeah both
of their kind of styles of acting
specifically to those two I was watching
this show this look like one of those
films I'm like Morgan Freeman would have
been an old guy yeah I went together
reunite this looks like the version of
that that could actually be kind of a
heartfelt film yes Oh guys cuz when they
started drinking and the shot I was like
oh god it's gonna go down this path
all the guys having fun yeah is there
gonna be a shot where they're like
skateboarding
I never got to that point and knowing
richard linklater I don't think it would
go down down that path besides all that
this was like a sweet film this looks
like something I would probably wait for
to watch on like Netflix or like someone
I know really wanted to go watch it I'm
probably I don't know if this is
something I'm gonna go out of my way to
go see it feels more like something you
might go out of your way to go see yeah
but even so I mean as a trailer in and
of itself this is one of those movies
where I am mostly interested because of
who's involved and what I know about
them it's like I feel like Richard
Linklater and the cast he's assembled
can make this into a great really
nuanced movie as a trailer I'm not like
oh this is amazing
you know yeah and there are other movies
of his that do get me more excited in a
trailer format like everybody wants some
I was like oh yeah when I go out and see
that this was like this could be really
touching I don't know exactly if it's
gonna cut a great trailer yeah is he
never knew Richard Linklater he can he
can usually write a pretty good line
between being heartfelt sometimes like
everybody wants some gets a little sappy
and you just never know and this looks
like the Capitol Mike it could be either
or it could get sad
it could get sappy or it could just be
really hard touching as far as these
like older guy movies go I feel like he
has the potential to bring something a
lot more than just you know fluff and
cute and sir he's only 25 years old yeah
but it seems like with a movie like this
especially that doesn't need to be
flashy I feel like he can probably
really work his magic on it yeah but you
know again I don't I don't think it's
the kind of movie that's gonna cut like
the most thrilling looking trailer well
guys um last flag flying it's kind of a
hard title to say last flag flying it is
a it is shaped interesting yeah last
flag flying you gotta really make sure
you say the L and that F word yeah
the last gay pilot concert temporarily
disabled people who rejects quick that
notification belt yeah John Humphrey on
twisting and stuff go check on our
patreon yay